getting in University has an excellent
reputation in Germany and a year ago the
Max Planck Institute for solar system
research moved to the campus here
gaining more direct access to the next
generation of top-notch researchers the
foyer boasts a model of the comet
churyumov-gerasimenko affectionately
called jury the mission - it illustrates
the Institute's role in exploring
neighbouring space from comets to
planets to stars experts here are
involved in the European Space Agency's
Rosetta mission and its groundbreaking
feel a lander one major reason for
Rosetta's high profile and exposure in
the media is the stunning photographs
it's delivered they were taken with a
camera developed at the Institute the
orbiter has been relaying close-ups of
Cheree back to earth since November
these pictures are key to solving
riddles posed by the Comets bizarre
landscape since the old the eye is our
primary sensory organs the one that
provides us with the most information
these images give us background data
which enables us to better interpret
other information from measurements
helping us to understand what it really
means you need a special kind of camera
to take a snapshot in outer space this
device can take pictures in seven
different wavelengths scientists back on
earth can use the images to identify
exactly which elements make up far-off
worlds
a twin of the model is aboard NASA's
Dawn spacecraft to ride Vesta and the
dwarf planet Ceres which are located
between Mars and Jupiter the designers
have to protect their cameras from a
wide range of dangers buddies and come
across is the challenge with these
cameras is that they have to work under
very extreme conditions they have to
withstand very high and very low
temperatures as well as cosmic radiation
and they have to be extremely reliable
because once a probe has been launched
there'll be no way to repair them my
nucleus the institute was founded back
in the 1930s when former managing
director Peter Tchaikovsky was still a
child its scientists initially focused
on atmospheric research in 1946 it
changed locations moving to a small town
in West Germany and two years later
formally became part of the Max Planck
group of Research Institute's its
scientists began launching balloons and
rockets to investigate the Earth's
stratosphere and beyond you haven't I
fly Lucas air horses good we were very
fortunate to have such a talented and
dedicated staff and a whole development
of the detectors for the cameras that
was all new territory they took a lot of
tests and trials Missoula Montana
which paid off soon the Institute was
writing history
europe's first interplanetary research
satellite carried a camera built by a
consortium headed by the institute and
its first images of the unprecedented
close encounter with Halley's Comet did
not disappoint
as the Huygens Lander prepared to
touchdown on Saturn's moon Titan in 2005
the event was captured on a camera
largely built by Max Planck researchers
it was a historic moment in the far
reaches of our solar system and the
Institute's contribution to the Mars
Pathfinder mission in 1997 even scooped
up a German TV or what does it take to
succeed in the field Yosh tinker's
employees often I'm liable we need
innovative scientists with ideas for
instruments that can record exciting
measurements missingno Dolf name then we
need engineers and technicians with the
expertise to turn those ideas into
working instruments GCD invocation for
silly and instrumental mrs. Edison and
of course facilities for actually
building those cutting-edge cameras
there's plenty of room in the
Institute's spacious new premises these
workshops are fitted with high-tech
machines for training the next
generation of pioneering electronic
engineers a vital human resource in the
research missions of the future
it's graduation day at the solar system
school a joint program run by the Max
Planck Institute with Gooding and
University it Awards doctoral
scholarships to junior researchers from
across the world
acquiring highly qualified future staff
for the Institute
back inside a state-of-the-art telescope
is currently being designed to supply
new insights into the sun's magnetic
field its mission will involve taking
ultra precise measurements under
inhospitable conditions the instrument
will have to overcome major temperature
fluctuations as well as the phenomenon
called the solar wind it's made up of a
stream of particles that can cause
circuits to short out so we have to
protect electronic components that might
mean hardening them making them
resistant to these particles
competition for the solar telescope job
was tough but the muck Splunk did got
the nod and the researchers are
confident of being awarded further
contracts for future pioneering space
missions
you